bonjour à tous je m'appelle nadine
pellen
j'ai 40 ans et si je suis devant vous
aujourd'hui c'est grâce à martin martin
et traductrice pour tout vous dire je
les appelais au mois de janvier pour lui
souhaiter la bonne année et je lui ai
demandé martine qu'est-ce que tu traduis
en ce moment elle me dit je traduis les
kits des conférences ted tu connais je
dois vous avouer je ne connaissais pas
du tout elle en explique le principe
c'est simple c'est de partager une idée
qui nous tient à coeur
donc si je suis devant vous aujourd'hui
c'est pour vous présenter un sujet qui
me tient à coeur
j'ai la mucoviscidose dans ma famille
deux de mes tantes sont décédées de
cette maladie une en 1953 l'autre en
1983 et très tôt je me suis demandé
pourquoi nous
est ce un hasard est ce une coïncidence
et puis est ce que mes descendants
seront prêts destinés à subir cette
maladie voilà le sujet de mon propos
aujourd'hui la mucoviscidose hasard ou
coïncidence ou prédestination
on va commencer par le hasard je vous
parle de la mucovisidose mais je
pourrais vous parler de tout autre toute
autre maladie
la drépanocytose la maladie de charcot
marie tooth là l'hémochromatose peu
importe je vous parle de la
mucoviscidose parce que c'est ce que je
connais qu'est ce que la mucoviscidose
le terme est composé de deux mouches du
cuss vie ce que je sais du mucus
visqueux qui s'accumule dans l'organisme
ma première tente est décédé en 1953
elle était maigrichonne mais elle avait
le ventre ballonné elle toussait elle
avait des diarrhées et de la fièvre
elle est partie à 16 mois
on ne connaissait pas encore la maladie
la coqueluche a dit le médecin
ma deuxième temps tu es né en 1966 les
symptômes étaient les mêmes tout
diarrhée et et maigrichonne le ventre
ballonné de la fièvre
mais entre temps les recherches avaient
avancé vie on avait vu nommer la maladie
la décrire une association de malades
c'était même réunis enfin jeudi de
malades mais de parents puisque
l'espérance de vie était de 7 ans un
centre de soins s'était ouvert à la
pointe de la bretagne à roscoff pour
prendre en charge les malades atteints
de cette maladie
ma deuxième temps de noël rapidement a
été dirigé vers le centre de perharidy à
roscoff
on lui a fait un test le test de la
sueur sa sueur était très très salée le
diagnostic est tombé
l'uqo visite aux en 1989 il ya eu une
révolution on a trouvé le gène codant
pour la mucoviscidose
ça a été un nouvel espoir dans les
familles on a vu à quoi il servait ce
gène
en fait ils servaient à préserver
l'équilibré entre l'eau et le sel dans
les cellules
mais si ce gène est muté il fonctionne
pas bien il ya un déséquilibre
d'hydratation des mucus et les mules
s'accumulent et alors là bonjour les
infections le blocage de digestion et
c'est donc la maladie a été décrite le
gène a été trouvé mais on est presque 30
ans plus tard et on ne guérit toujours
pas de la mucoviscidose
soyons pas pessimistes en 2002 depuis
2002 tous les enfants qui naissent en
france sont testées pour savoir s'ils
sont malades ou non s'ils sont malades
ils sont dirigés très rapidement vers un
centre
soins spécialisés pour les prendre en
charge et là la bataille commence
tous les jours ils doivent prendre des
médicaments des enzymes pancréatiques
des antibiotiques des vitamines
il faut doit faire de la kiné monde
rennais ce mucus
c'est une bataille quotidienne en plus
ça se voit par physiquement la
mucoviscidose mais avec cette prise en
charge précoce cette bataille
quotidienne et bien les malades ont
gagné de l'espérance de vie
aujourd'hui un enfant qui naît
aujourd'hui en france son espérance de
vie est de 40 ans donc voilà rapidement
pour la mucoviscidose
je suis porteuse saine de la
mucoviscidose
est ce un hasard non je vais vous
expliquer comment ce gène est venue
jusqu'à moi vous aimez bien les dragibus
ce que j'ai fait une présentation à base
de dragibus pour vous expliquer comment
la mucoviscidose est arrivé jusqu'à moi
à l'origine dans ma famille dans la
famille dragibus y avait que des trajets
bus jaune
et puis il ya une mutation
il ya maintenant des dragibus picot lors
c'est le cas de mes grands parents ils
sont tous les deux porteurs sains d'un
gène de la mucoviscidose
voici ce qui se passe à chaque
conception d'enfants chacun le papa et
la maman donne une partie
de son patrimoine génétique tous les
deux donc le premier dans le premier cas
l'enfant il est non porter parce qu'il a
reçu un gel non muté de chacun de ses
parents prenons un deuxième cas est un
troisième ses deux enfants ont reçu un
gène muté de leurs parents ils sont
porteurs sains et dans le quatrième
quart dragibus orange est malade il a
reçu deux gènes mutés de chacun de ses
parents ingénuité de chacun de ses
parents
mes grands parents ont eu cinq enfants
la première dragibus orange le deuxième
il est décédé avant d'avoir fait le test
3 et 4 dragibus bicolore et la cinquième
dragibus orange malade sa c'est le cas
de mes grands parents
cette loterie c'est à chaque grossesse à
chaque conception qu'elle se renouvelle
prenons le cas de mes parents ma mère et
non porteuses mais elle ne le savait pas
elle a vécu ses grossesses
dans l' angoisse de mettre au monde un
enfant malade mais
elle n'était pas porteuse elle pouvait
pas transmettre le gène muté mon papa
est porteur sain mais il ne le savait
pas il savait simplement qu'il avait
hérité probabilité d'avoir un enfant
malade il a transmis
il était porteur sain il a transmis une
partie de son patrimoine génétique
moi je fais partie des deux trajets bus
de droite puisque le jeu supporte scène
mes parents ont eu trois enfants
on est trois porteurs c'est la loterie
à chaque achat conception en france il
ya sept mille malades atteints de
mucoviscidose et nous sommes environ 2
millions de porteurs sains moi j'ai la
chance je le sèche
la plupart ne le savent pas moi je le
sais que c'est pas par hasard que je l'
ai vu je sais qu'il fait ce gène fait
partie de mon histoire familiale
mais la question est est-ce une
coïncidence
est ce une coïncidence si mes grands
parents sont tous les deux porteurs
sains et s'ils ont eu deux enfants
malades en france il ya une naissance
d'enfants malades pour 4900 naissance en
bretagne il ya une naissance d'enfants
malades sur environ trois mille
naissances et en bretagne je vous le
donne en mille dans quel département
l'incidence est la plus élevée c'est le
finistère une naissance d'enfants
malades sur 2200 naissance et dans le
finistère
une étude avait été fait
elle date 1 entre 1946 et 1972
une naissance d'enfants malades sur 377
naissance mes grands parents sont nés
dans le canton de berne 20 pouces dvd
dans le dos ainsi dans sa
j'ai pas voulu en rester là je sais je
suis porteuse ça fait partie de mon
histoire familiale
il y a quand même de forte coïncidence
pour que j'aie des ancêtres porter mais
j'ai voulu aller plus loin j'ai
interrogé des médecins des généticiens
pour savoir d'où venaient ces mutations
personne ne m'a répondu du coup j'ai
décidé de mener moi-même l'enquète et je
me suis inscrite en thèse je vais pas
vous raconter dix ans de recherche en
cinq minutes
je vais simplement vous dire que j'ai
remonté beaucoup beaucoup d'un
généalogique de malades atteints de
mucoviscidose
pour quel résultat sur cette carte on
voit où vivent les ancêtres des porteurs
d'une mutation très fréquente en
bretagne sur cette deuxième carte
on voit où vivent les ancêtres des
porteurs d'une autre mutation de la
mucoviscidose et sur cette troisième
carte
on voit où vivent les ancêtres d'une
troisième mutation on voit que en
remontant les arbres généalogiques des
malades jusqu'au 16e siècle on voit que
selon les mutations il y à une
répartition différentiel des malades et
de leurs ancêtres par mutation d'accord
très bien mais je connaissais cette
carte je savais que les bretons
et est issu de migration c'est à dire
43e siècle en bretagne il y avait
quasiment personne et entre le troisième
et le 7ème siècle
il ya eu de très grandes migrations mon
idée c'est donc que la mucoviscidose
serait venu avec les migrants et cette
mutation de ces mutations dans leurs
bagages
et c'est sûrement ce qui s'est passé
parce que la mutation que l'on retrouve
surtout dans l ouest du département dans
le nord ouest
on la retrouve beaucoup en irlande la
mutation que d'autres l'ont retrouvé
dans le sud de la bretagne cette
mutation on ne l'a retrouvé que en pays
bigouden et au pays de galles il ya
sûrement un lien entre ces deux
populations
de même entre la cornouaille anglaise et
la cornouaille armoricaine donc ce qui
s'est passé c'est qu'entre le troisième
est le septième siècle
il ya eu des grandes migrations qui se
sont faites par clans et les migrants se
sont posés et sont restés là pendant des
siècles et des siècles sans qu'il y ait
eu de brassage génétique
je vous entends d'ici consanguinité vous
allez me dire non non non je vous arrête
tout de suite les les mutations étaient
tellement présent dans la population que
par absence de brassage génétique
les porteurs sains se sont développées
au fur et à mesure des générations et
les jettera gibus orange aussi par une
très grande stabilité géographique n'y a
pas une mélange entre ces clans de
migrants je vais vous montrer une carte
ici vivait un couple il ya onze
générations ce couple il a plus de 100
malades dans sa descendance et voici
vives et descendants génération
génération pour ce que j'ai dans ma base
de données donc à la génération c 5 4 3
2 1
jusqu'à maintenant on voit qu'on est là
en présence d'une stabilité géographique
qu'il n'y a pas eu de brassage génétique
et cette stabilité géographique a pour
conséquence que les dragibus bicolore
gagne du terrain
donc les coïncidences voiliers sont très
nombreuses mais la troisième question
c'est qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour arrêter
ça est ce que on est vraiment frais
destiné à le subir
en 1996 est née à paris a hélas elle
avait le ventre ballonné la sueur saleh
elle était maigrichonne elle toussait la
veine et diarrhées le diagnostic est
très vite tombé j'ai une copie 6 2 si
vous avez bien suivi son papa et sa
maman sont tous les deux porteurs moi
même je supporte pas ce que va pas y
porter mais pas maman ma grand-mère est
porteuse mon arrière grand père et
porter mon arrière arrière grand père
aussi
et cet arrière arrière grand père il a
une soeur qui a une fille qui a une vie
qui a un physique qui est le papa de la
petite taille né à paris en 1996 quand
je les suis je me suis dit c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible
est-ce qu'on va subir cette
prédestination pendant encore des années
des siècles et des siècles
il faut arrêter cette chaîne qui se
transmettent de génération en génération
aujourd'hui il existe pas de médicaments
modifier le gène muté de la
mucoviscidose
mais il existe un dépistage est porteur
sain ça coûte à peu près 100 euros
centaines d'euros vous quand on a un
malade dans la famille c'est remboursé
dans la sécu moi je les fais ce test je
suis très contente quand je me suis
marié j'ai dit à mon mari tu le fais
aussi et il l'a fait non porteurs ouf
mais s'il l'avait fait s'il était
porteur on aurait pu faire des choix
éclairés
on aurait pu décider de mettre au monde
un enfant malade ou pas on sait pas
quels choix on aurait fait mais on
aurait eu le choix
je dis pas qu'il faut plus avoir de
dragibus orange c'est parce que je veux
dire
mais je veux dire que c'est important de
pouvoir faire des choix éclairés
moi je suis contente d'avoir dû faire ce
choix et quand je demande aux parents
d'un enfant malade
leur situation ils me disent tous si on
avait su si on avait su moi j'ai trois
enfants ils sont pas malades
si vous avez bien suivi puisque mon mari
n'est pas porteur et qui mené à la
naissance ils ont été dépistés ils sont
pas malades
je ne sais pas s'ils sont porteurs sains
ou pas ils pourront faire le test
quand ils auront 18 ans mais ils ont la
chance de savoir qu'on a cette maladie
dans la famille et qu'ils pourront faire
ce test là combien vous êtes dans la
salle petite centaine et ben y en a six
d'entre vous qui sont porteurs ça je la
mucoviscidose je veux que mes enfants
leurs cousins vos enfants leurs cousins
puisse faire le test de la mucoviscidose
le test de dépistage est porteur sain et
bon ton matos maladie de charcot marie
tooth drépanocytose tous ces noms
barbares cache une maladie une maladie
qui est présente dans notre patrimoine
génétique mais dans dix quinze vingt ans
elle sera toujours la main il faut en
finir avec la prédestination
pour conclure je vous dirais qu'une
solution existe
c'est le test des dépistages des
porteurs sains nous porteurs sains
sépare nous que se transmet la maladie
y a que nous qui pouvons l'arrêter
comment faire c'est simple si vous avez
un malade dans le votre famille même
éloigné même très éloignées vous l'avez
vu eh bien il faut prendre rendez-vous
au chu avec un conseiller en génétique
pour faire le test
c'est aussi simple que ça la
connaissance vaut toujours mieux que
l'ignorance c'est l'idée que je voulais
faire passer devant vous aujourd'hui et
c'est bizarre vous rappeler le livre que
martin a traduit et ben ma conclusion
elle rejoint complètement celle de chris
anderson notre avenir nous appartient
peu importe ce que la vie nous a donnée
qui nous pouvons le façonner et cela
peut changer la vie des autres aussi
avant de vous quitter je vais vous dire
une dernière chose chez haribo
ils ont arrêté la production de dragibus
orange
c'est un signe non
merci
[Applaudissements]